>> Laura: HUNDREDS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE PREPARING TO
CROSS INTO CALIFORNIA AND ASK
FOR POLITICAL ASYLUM.
WHAT IS MORE OUTRAGEOUS, THIS
CARAVAN OF CENTRAL AMERICANS HAS
BEEN ORGANIZED, AIDED AN ABETTED
AND COACHED BY U.S.-BASED
ACTIVISTS FROM A GROUP.
WHY HAS MEDIA TURNED A BLIND EYE
TO THE ROLE PLAYED BY THE
PROJECT'S COORDINATOR, ALEX
MENSING WHO IS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO'S
IMMIGRATION CLINIC?
LET'S GET INTO THAT WITH DAN
STEIN IN TAMPA AND FRANCISCO
HERNANDEZ IN FORT WORTH, TEXAS.
DAN, LET'S START WITH YOU HERE.
THIS IS QUITE SOMETHING.
WE HAVE AMERICAN NGOs AND OTHER
NGOs WORKING TO GET THE
PUBLICITY GOING FOR THIS GROUP.
THEY COME EVERY YEAR ABOUT
EASTER TIME AND MAKE THEIR WAY
TO MEXICO.
MEXICO USUALLY DISBANDS THEM
EFFECTIVELY.
THEY STARTED TO DISBAND THEM
BEFORE I THINK THE PRESIDENT
STARTED TWEETING ABOUT IT A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
BUT YOU HAVE THESE LAWYERS THAT
BASICALLY EMBED WITH THE GROUP
WHO ARE AMERICAN LAWYERS.
THEY'RE GOING OVER, OKAY, THIS
IS WHAT YOU SAY FOR CREDIBLE
FEAR OF PERSECUTION AND THEN
THEY SHOW UP ON BUSES AND THEN
THEY ALL START RECITING THE SAME
LINE.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO GAIN THE SYSTEM.
>> LAURA, IT'S AIDING AND
ABETTING AND ORGANIZED
SMUGGLING.
THE MEDIA SAYS IT'S LIKE A
STREET FAIR, THEY'RE COMING IN
FOR A FESTIVAL AND GOING BACK TO
HONDURAS.
THIS IS ORGANIZED SMUGGLING.
AS LONG AS THE UNITED STATES IS
A FREE CAPITALIST AND OPEN
SOCIETY, THERE WILL BE MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE THAT WANT TO COME
HERE.
NOT EVERYBODY CAN COME AND A
SOVEREIGN NATION LIKE THE U.S.
HAS A RIGHT TO CONTROL WHO COMES
IN AND WHO DOESN'T.
GROUPS LIKE PEOPLE WITHOUT
BORDERS DO NOT SUBSCRIBE TO THAT
IDEA.
SO THIS EFFORT IS PART OF AN
ORGANIZED EFFORT WE SEE ACROSS
THE WORLD.
WE SEE IT IN EUROPE AND THE GAZA
WITH ISRAEL AND ALL AROUND THE
WORLD TO TRY TO CHALLENGE
WESTERN SOCIETIES TO PREVENT
THEM FROM USING THEIR
IMMIGRATION LAWS TO STOP THIS
ORGANIZED SMUGGLING UNDER THE
BAN OF ASYLUM.
I FEEL SORRY FOR THE PEOPLE.
IF ONLY REFUGEES CAN GET IN.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE CALLED A
REFUGEE.
SO THEY GET COACHED IN.
THEY KNOW IF THEY MAKE A
CREDIBLE FEAR CLAIM, IF THERE'S
NO DETENTION SPACE, THEY'LL BE
RELEASED FOR YEARS BEFORE THEY
GET THEIR HEARING AND LUCKILY
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
TAKING STEPS TO STOP THIS BY
DEPLOYING IMMIGRATION JUDGES TO
EXTRADITE THEIR REMOVAL.
>> FRANCISCO, MEXICO HAS TRIED
TO HELP OUT HERE AT VARIOUS
POINTS INCLUDING BY, YOU KNOW,
TELLING THE FOLKS, LOOK, YOU
HAVE 30 DAYS TO LEAVE MEXICO.
WE'LL GIVE YOU A TRANSIT VISA
AND YOU HAVE TO LEAVE MEXICO.
THEIR POINT IS, MEXICAN
OFFICIALS HAVE SAID IF YOU WANT
ASYLUM, WE'LL GIVE YOU ASYLUM.
BUT THEY HAVE MADE IT CLEAR IN
VARIOUS SOURCES HAVE TOLD ME
THAT THE HONDURANS
OVERWHELMINGLY DON'T WANT TO BE
IN MEXICO.
SO THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED IN
GOING TO ANY COUNTRY EXCEPT OUR
COUNTRY.
WHY IS THAT?
>> EXCEPT THE PROMISED LAND.
LISTEN TO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
ARE WE NOW AGAINST LEGAL
IMMIGRATION?
ASYLUM LAW IS A LEGAL PROCESS BY
WHICH THESE FOLKS CAN APPLIED TO
COME IN.
THEY EITHER HAVE PROOF OR THEY
DON'T.
YOU CAN'T COACH PROOF.
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO COME IN
UNDER A LEGAL PROCESS.
THAT IS OUR LAW.
THEY'RE NOT COMING ACROSS.
THERE'S NO SMUGGLING, NO ILLEGAL
ENTRY INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THEY'RE A PLAYING TO COME INTO
THE UNITED STATES
THE UNITED STATE
THE UNITED STATES LEGALLY.
ISN'T THAT WHAT WE WANTED?
IF THERE'S 400 AT THE BORDER,
BRING THEM SOME BRICKS AND THEY
CAN BUILD THE WALL.
>> SINCE WE SPENT $16 BILLION
ALL TOLD ON ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
THAT WOULD BE FIVE WALLS.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
THAT COME HERE ILLEGALLY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE INTERVIEWED
HAVE SAID --
>> NO.
>> Laura: HOLD ON.
THEY HAVE DISBANDED FROM THE
GROUP AND SAY WE'RE GOING TO GET
THERE.
WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE IF WE
DON'T GET IN AS ASSILEES --
>> WHAT ABOUT LEGAL IMMIGRATION?
THEY'RE INVOKING ASYLUM LAWS
THAT IS THE LAW OF THE LAND.
>> Laura: FRANCISCO, ARE YOU
SAYING YOU DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
FRAUD IN THE ASYLUM --
APPLICATION OF THE ASYLUM LAWS?
>> SURE THERE IS.
>> Laura: IT'S RAMPANT.
>> AND IMMIGRATION IS VERY GOOD
AT FERRETING IT OUT.
THE PROOF IS --
>> Laura: WHAT IS -- FRANCISCO,
YOU'RE AN IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY.
YOU THINK THESE -- YOU THINK
THAT 24-YEAR-OLD MOTHER OF THREE
IS PUTTING ON WITNESSES AND --
HERE'S MY DOCUMENTS.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY DOCUMENTS
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> MRS. INGRAM --
>> Laura: CALL ME LAURA.
>> THE U.S. AGENTS -- THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S AGENTS ARE
GROWING TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THESE PEOPLE CAN PROVE IMMEDIATE
FEAR.
IT'S NOT LIKE THERE'S ALL THESE
SOCIAL PROGRAMS GOING OUT.
IT'S A HARD THRESHOLD TO PROVE.
IT'S A LEGAL WAY OF INVOKING THE
LAWS OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: I THINK IT'S 75 TO 93%
OF PEOPLE THAT APPLY FOR ASYLUM
IN THIS PROCESS GET IT OR
ULTIMATELY GET RELEASED ANYWAY
DURING THE PROCESS --
>> NO, LESS THAN 10%.
>> Laura: THEY GET RELEASED
INTO -- DAN, DO THEY NOT GET
RELEASED AFTER THEY APPLIED --
>> THE FIRST IS WHAT IS CALL
CREDIBLE FEAR.
IT'S A LOW THRESHOLD.
ALL YOU HAVE TO SAY IS I'M
AFRAID TO GO HOME.
THEY CAN REQUEST A JUDGE.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY GET BACK
LOCKED AND RELEASED TO SOCIETY
AND HERE FOR YEARS.
I WISH HAD A DOLLAR FOR EVERY
TIME THEY DON'T SHOW UP FOR
THEIR HEARING OR DEPORTATION --
IT GOES ON AND ON.
>> OKAY --
>> Laura: HOLD ON A SECOND.
>> THERE IS A MASSIVE MESS.
>> IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT, FIX THE
LAW.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
TRYING TO CHANGE THE LAW.
>> Laura: FRANCISCO, YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
>> CHECK THIS OUT --
>> Laura: HOLD ON.
FRANCISCO, YOU'RE RIGHT.
THIS LAWS DO NEED TO BE CHANGED.
THE WAY THE ASYLUM LAWS ARE
WRITTEN NOW ARE -- IT'S EASILY
GAMABLE.
IF THAT'S EVEN A WORD.
IT'S EASILY GAMED AND IT DOES
HAVE TO BE CHANGED BECAUSE IT'S
ACTUALLY PUTTING THE MIGRANT'S
LIVES AT RISK.
YOU HAVE THESE KIDS CROSSING
THAT ARE BEING MANIPULATED --
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> Laura: AND BEING HURT BY THE
GANGS AND RECRUITED BY GANGS.
THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN NIGHT
THAT WE HELPED CREATE.
>> GOD BLESS YOU FOR SAYING
THAT.
YOU'RE CORRECT.
>> Laura: WE'RE RUNNING OVER.
THIS JUST CAME OUT TODAY.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LOSES
TRACK OF 20% OF THE
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN WITHIN
THREE MONTHS OF THEIR ARRIVING
HERE, THIS IS HHS TESTIMONY
TODAY.
THEY HAVE LOST TRACK OF 7,635
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN THAT THEY
HAD TO CHECK IN WITH OVER THE
LAST THREE MONTHS OF LAST YEAR.
THEY LOST TRACK OF 1,500 OF
THOSE AFTER 30 DAYS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT ARE.
>> AND THE PEOPLE ARE --
>> MANY OF THE PEOPLE SAY
THEY'RE FLEEING -- THEY SAY
THEY'RE FLEEING GANG VIOLENCE.
THE MINORS ARE ACTUALLY
RECRUITED BY MS-13 --
>> Laura: WE'RE OUT OF TIME.
>> WE HAVE A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP --
>> Laura: WE AGREED ON
SOMETHING.
>> I'LL MEET YOU AT THE BORDER.
>> Laura: FRANCISCO, WE'RE GOING